it's a gateway to crime it's a gateway
to addiction could make the same claims
about alcohol because it is such a
popular drug correlation again well you
can correlate it any way you want
Roger Morgan is an anti-drug activist
determined to stop marijuana
legalization in California
he's spearheading the stop Pot 2016
campaign which sets him and his group up
as the main opponents of the marijuana
legalization initiative championed by
the likes of lieutenant governor Gavin
Newsom and Napster founder Sean Parker
Morgan sat down with us to talk about
his initiative the safe and drug-free
community Act which aims to keep
commercial marijuana illegal and to more
heavily regulate the state's medical
marijuana Roger Morgan thank you very
much for talking to us thank you my
pleasure mmm public opinion since at
least 2013 has turned against marijuana
prohibition how do you expect to contend
with that especially in California you
know I'm not sure that it has changed
dramatically the other guys have a lot
of control over the media there's public
opinion polling that has shown that more
than 50% of the public wants to legalize
marijuana nationwide yeah we fought the
same battle with prop 19 public opinion
polls showed that people favored that
when we finally got to the polls the
result was different well with the safe
and drug-free community act - could you
summarize those yeah number one it would
preserve the intent of 215 to make
marijuana available for the chronically
ill for whom it was really intended I'm
not sure that the benefits outweigh the
harms but so that we don't have to
contend with that issue I'm saying we'll
keep it but what it does do is eliminate
the abuses that we've encountered in 19
years of no regulations it would ban
privately owned cultivation sites and
dispensaries the dispensaries are
nothing more than retail drug dealers
with a storefront so you want to keep
medical marijuana legal but you want the
state to run all of the dispensaries and
cultivate all the marijuana why would we
want the government growing and selling
well in an ideal world in an ideal world
we wouldn't but the idea is that if we
must have it if the government has one
cultivation site it doesn't suck up all
the water and our drought you know a
plant consumes six gallons of water per
day per plant it seems like if you were
bringing it above board you'd have
legitimate people growing it just like
they grow any other crop and the water
issues and so forth would be dealt with
the exact same way isn't that true I
don't think so I don't know of any plant
that consumes the amount of water that
marijuana does number one but secondly
you have to remember this is a dangerous
drug it inflicts brain damage on anybody
less than 25 years old permanent brain
damage the legalization initiative of
course is only for adults 21 and over
so does talking about what it does to
minors is that really affair they don't
they're not talking about getting rid of
the medical marijuana mess that we
already have and that's 18 and over so
if you're it's almost become a rite of
passage to be 18 years old get a pot
doctor's recommendation for 20 or 30
bucks and then you can buy all the pot
you want for a year when kids think
there's no harm to marijuana more kids
use it it's the gateway to other drugs
that kill by overdose like heroin saying
that marijuana is a gateway drug is a
myth
lots of people who use harder drugs have
used marijuana but the same is true
again of alcohol it's a correlation not
a causation necessarily it there's no
evidence that using marijuana is what
those are the harder drugs Zac there's a
lot of evidence to that I know alcohol
and tobacco are gateways to a lifestyle
where they use drugs but almost
everybody that has gone on to other
drugs started with marijuana now there's
recent indications that from NIDA
National Institute of drug addiction
that 70% start with marijuana if you
talk to anybody that's dealt with
addiction and the prisons of the rehab
system they'll tell you everybody
started with marijuana I'm glad you
brought up night of the National
Institute of drug abuse because they
themselves have said the evidence
regarding brain function and marijuana
is mixed at best and this
is the government agency that is
supposed to study the harms of drugs
NIDA was involved in a long-term study
at New Zealand of over a thousand people
that went from adolescence to age 38 and
they found a loss of IQ of up to 8
points again it could be correlation and
not causation now that's the common for
his correlation not causation I just
tell you that having been doing this for
20 years I probably studied more
research than most people on earth about
marijuana it's a gateway to crime it's a
gateway to addiction I live with
addiction in my family for 20 years two
kids had started at 12 and 14 again to
say that it's a gateway to crime or a
gateway to addiction it could make the
same claims about alcohol because it is
such a popular drug it's there in so
many cases of people who are arrested
yeah correlation again well you can
correlate it any way you want but you
look at driving deaths they have doubled
in California Washington Colorado
because of marijuana impairment and and
the number of deaths because of that are
almost on a par or maybe have exceeded
alcohol-related duis at this point
Colorado there if you look at their
highway traffic fatalities since the
state started selling marijuana they're
actually at a all-time low in terms of
the average so you would expect to see a
big spike in highway fatalities if the
introduction of more marijuana was
causing people to drive more around
would you not I'm just gonna tell you
that all the studies that everybody is
done indicate that marijuana is it
doesn't that make you a safer driver the
National Highway Traffic and Safety
Administration actually studied this
question of driving on marijuana and
they found that there's no significantly
elevated traffic risk for someone on
marijuana so saying that it's causing
more accidents is a dubious claim Zak
I'm I didn't invent any of this and you
can believe what you want to believe but
we work with a guy named Alec rancer who
is retired from the National Highway
Traffic Safety Board and we've been
working with NIDA and another pharmacist
named Phil Drum whose sister was killed
by a marijuana impaired driver in
Washington the the question is it's very
difficult to come up with a
blood-alcohol content
equivalent of alcohol nobody wants
people who are intoxicated under any
circumstances to be getting behind the
wheel of a car it's just a matter of how
do you measure it how do you measure it
with alcohol it's a little bit different
with marijuana and that's built in to
the Newsom Parker law so isn't that a
positive the problem is or if they're in
an accident
it takes three or four hours before you
take the test in in most cases the
marijuana has flushed itself out of the
system out of the blood didn't test the
brain how do you justify the massive use
of public resources that go towards
enforcing the laws against this drug
well let me need to tell you that what
hasn't been publicized widely is that
almost all of the mass murders that
we've had in recent years the person has
been a heavy marijuana user because it
changes the brain if you look at the
Tucson shooting Aurora Paris recently
the guy was a complete stoner according
to his ex-girlfriend even the radical
Islam's that are doing that that's how
they changed the motivation of younger
people as they give them marijuana so
marijuana is causing America's mass
shootings and Europe's as well it is a
major factor in it and it again is a
causal factor not a correlated factor
it's a causal factor in mental illness
and how exactly have scientists proven
that marijuana causes mental illness and
causes people to snap and go shoot up a
church or a coffee shop they again
there's thousands of studies that have
shown us and a lot of brain scan
technology
so you're saying they've isolated the
changes in the brain
someone to go shoot up a church yes I'm
saying you they have psychotic breaks
that have lost by marijuana caused by
marijuana you don't believe it but I'm
just telling okay
okay every scientific research project
ends with we need to study this further
so I would tell you the same thing you
and I obviously have disagreements of in
terms of what the science says about the
actual known harms of marijuana
we've had it illegal for 40-plus years
it's just as popular as ever from a
practical standpoint is keeping it
illegal really the best way to reduce
the harms that can come from this drug
yes
keeping it illegal and enforcing the law
is what has to happen so we need more
resources going to the DEA and kind of I
wasn't sure we got supply we've spent 40
years in the trillion dollars trying to
interdict the supply we're not going to
do it what's missing is that the
government has never had the will or the
courage or the wisdom to do what works
to prevent the disease and what you have
to do today to do that you've got to
have education you can educate without
making something illegal though you can
educate without making it legal or
illegal you you have to educate people
and get the word out you don't have to
make something illegal you can just make
your case like you are to me and say
make up your own mind you don't need to
bring in the power of the state and say
ok we're going to arrest you and put you
in jail so let's just talk about that
you're right parents and all the groups
I've talked to parents particularly are
unaware of the harms that marijuana
impacts on the brain parents need to
know
either way they vote for this marijuana
can destroy this country if we continue
to destroy the brains of our young
people and allow the devastation of our
natural forests neither have a future in
order we as a nation Roger Morgan thank
you very much for your time thank you my
friend for recent TV I'm Zak why similar